[Music]
[Applause]
Woody paid ESPN Around the Horn
contributor and uh Denver Gazette
columnist and uh how's morale in Denver
today Woody
I want you to say hello to my little
friend oh Woody oh there he is I'm Buzz
Lightyear I can fly
I just felt like I should bring a prop
uh how's morale today in Denver
well it looks like it's gonna snow
that tends to make people uh unhappy but
we saw a game last night that uh blogged
into leather helmet period of football I
think if that didn't prove that there
doesn't belong a Thursday night football
game I don't know what would neither
team looked like they wanted to play
okay but but I called it horse fit but
if I look at the Broncos they're a
couple plays from being four and one and
granted they're not a four in one type
team but they're they're not that far
away from winning these games even
though they haven't been impressive so
if you look at this at what point do you
say this is who the Broncos are going to
be this season after five games is this
who these Broncos are yeah I don't think
we're at the Bill Parcells point where
you are what you are
what's lost in all of this is the
Broncos really have a great defense it's
in the top three four in the league and
they're doing it without Justin Simmons
who's an All-Pro they lost Gregory last
night he wasn't able to play in the game
and Browning got hurt Josie Jewel a
starter linebacker and they still
managed to give up uh four field goals
they they have been playing defensively
incredibly now I've gotten that out of
the way Russell Wilson had a bad
shoulder uh during the week and it
looked like it last night I mean he
couldn't hit the side of a barn as we
would say in the South and he has been
to be fair he's been terrible
So when you say they could have won four
games
yes but they need Russell Wilson that we
all know Russell Wilson is they needed
uh
Melvin Gordon to be what he used to be
in San Diego
they need an offensive line that's good
and it's not very good they have no
tight ends whatsoever they're dependent
totally on Cortland Sutton and and Jerry
Judy and Jerry Judy really has not
developed into the first round draft
choice that he was in that year of all
the great young wide receivers drafted
so when you say that they should be Ford
one they could be easily holding five on
the other side because offensively
they're just just horrific and I
wondered about Nathaniel Hackett in
terms of not being fired they're not
going to fire anybody but here's a guy
that is bringing in more coach he
already has more coaches than anybody in
the league and now he's got 31 assistant
coaches can you believe that I remember
when teams in Denver had six
defensive and offensive coaches but you
mentioned the defense Woody and that's
what I didn't understand the play
calling why not kick the field goal want
to go up by six Colts have no timeouts
there's going to be two minutes left
just under two minutes left and make
them go the field to score a touchdown
against your defense
that to me makes the most sense at home
well what they've done this year hasn't
made any sense uh what they did here's
an interesting point last night after
the game Hackett told us he said I
wanted to win the game I wanted to put
in Russell's uh place to to go for it on
fourth down this is the same coach who
didn't want to put in Russell Wilson
dance in Seattle he chose to kick the
longest field goals in the history of
the NFL and it certainly didn't work out
this spot job is too big for Nathaniel
Hackett at this point everybody thought
he was a guy that worked with with uh
with Aaron Rodgers he was with the Green
Bay Packers they had an incredible
offense he was the offensive coordinator
he never called the place and even
Rogers has said again recently oh he
made being at the practice fun he made
me he turned me around and made me enjoy
the game again that's not happening here
you ask about morale I've given you a
long-winded answer but the there were
people leaving the stadium
at the end of regulation
can you imagine you just mentioned
Jurassic Park that the original Jurassic
Park would you have left the movie
theater when you're getting to the
climax of the movie why in the world
would you come out last night if you
didn't want to see an overtime game the
last time we saw an overtime game in
Denver a guy named Tebow was throwing
the football in overtime to beat
Pittsburgh in the playoffs so I I morale
people booing the Broncos all the time
every game they've been booed on the
road and at home they were booted in
Vegas because they were 10 or 20 000
Broncos fans there it's a bad situation
but people expected with a new coach a
new general revenge or from two years
ago new quarterback that's been an
All-Pro forever and a new ownership that
paid the record amounts in North America
for franchise and you got this mess that
they've had under Vic Van Geo Advanced
Joseph for the last five years sure
morale is at its lowest point last night
I think they turned the light blue and
red lights or blue and orange lights
that they had on City Hall I think they
turned them off at the 13th
it feels like this is open season on
Russell Wilson
why do you think that is that you know
he feels like he's a Hall of Fame
quarterback feels nationally it's open
season unrest
he was supposed to come here after the
string of a dozen quarterbacks since
Peyton Manning retired and turned the
situation around B Russell Wilson of not
last year he was hurt four or five games
last year but the Russell Wilson of the
past you have to wonder now in Denver
if the Seattle Seahawks said
Gee it's time to get rid of him he's
turned the corner he's on the slide down
rather than the rise up because they got
a boatload of draft picks and a couple
of players and he has been mediocre I
mean that's the best thing what he does
best is get outside find a play they
aren't doing that they're trying to keep
him in the pocket he's trying to adjust
to a
Aaron Rodgers type offense where Rogers
would occasionally take off does it
occasionally take off and run but rarely
but Russell Wilson I don't in the
offense with uh Nathaniel Hackett hasn't
worked and he doesn't have the talent at
tight end this is the worst room for
tight ends in the league and they just
really don't have options uh offensively
and now they lose Williams their best
running back and they looked they looked
horrendous last night but they they're
the worst team in the league when they
get in the red zone and you ask them why
they didn't kick the field goal when you
can't score or a touchdown you've got to
keep yourself in the game and kick a
field goal and what's funny you know
I'll end on this is
Hackett brought in a veteran coach to
help him make those decisions in rosberg
and he's still making bad decisions on
timeouts uh game management it's a
pitiful situation here they look
pathetic last night but both teams Matt
Ryan
and Russell Wilson
don't look like the guys that won Super
Bowls they look like guys that should
retire
uh good to talk to you as always Woody
are you on around the horn today
uh I don't think so I I tried to beg in
to talk about the baseball playoffs but
they said uh we'll save you the money
Monday oh oh I think they're trying to
save them money
uh thank you Woody great to talk to you
again uh say hello to all the guys I
will that's a woody paid ESPN Around the
Horn contributor for uh 20 years now
Denver Gazette columnist uh Woody said
hi to you guys by the way
hi buddy yeah
he can't hear you when you wave though